the lightning round is a nice
interactive technique that I use in my
class and what we do is I divide the
group into usually two teams two sides
and I have them face each other so you
can have them face each other in in two
parallel lines or you can have an inner
circle and an outer circle as long as
one person is facing only one other
person and then you can you can you can
do it on a topic similar to the debate
where there's really two sides and you
ask the one side to take one side and
the other side to take another side but
the difference with this is that the
communication is only between the
student and the student that he or she
is facing and they only have one or two
minutes for the interaction so one
student gets to speak for say it's a
minute and the other student gets to
respond for a minute and then after
that's over I asked one line to shift or
one circle to take a step to the right
or the left and now each person has a
new partner that they to speak with
generally speaking if you had one row be
the pro and the other row be the con
then for the next iteration you would
have you would switch roles so there
would be the con and the pro the
advantages of this technique are that
they students get to hear a lot of
different opinions from a lot of
different students the fact that it
takes only two minutes that most for
each interaction means that that this
you can do it several times four times
five times if you do it five times it's
only about 10 minutes maybe 13 minutes
with some time to translate so so it's a
pretty quick exercise and by doing this
lightning round you can get different
students can get many different
perspectives from other students the
other the other kind of question you can
ask with a lightning round is you can
ask a question maybe you give students a
few minutes beforehand to do a
calculation or to solve a particular
kind of problem and then you say okay
you have one minute to explain how you
did the problem to your partner and your
partner has one minute to explain how he
or she did the problem to you and again
that lets students see other students
approaches and it lets them
think about their own their own approach
in the context of the other person's
approach you also tell them they're
allowed to change the way they think
about the problem or to think about the
response based on what they've heard and
their previous pairing so it lets
students kind of iterate and and develop
their opinions kind of as they go a
couple disadvantages of the technique
are that it's it's very very noisy so
students are speaking with each other
they're really only about a foot apart
and everyone is speaking at the same
time so depending on the class depending
on the personalities depending on the
people in the class it may not be such a
great technique but the advantage is
that it really gets everybody up it gets
everybody moving even people that are
really shy there's virtually nobody that
will stand there for a minute and not
say anything even people that are
extremely shy are generally willing to
talk with one other person and since you
can't hear anything about what's going
on in other groups or even the
instructor can't hear what's going on
it's a fairly safe conversational
situation so that is an advantage of it
my the thing I like about it the most is
that it gets students up it gets it
gives them the opportunity to formulate
an argument and to listen to the
argument of others and then put their
opinion or argument or answer in the
context of other answers and it lets
them hear the opinions and responses of
a lot of their peers in a very short
period of time after I finished the
lightning around I always give students
a minute or two minutes three minutes to
sort of sit down and reflect on the
exercise what they learned what what if
their answer changed how it changed why
it changed and then we usually do a
large group report out to say to say
this is you know I thought this going in
but I heard from so-and-so and this is
what I think now so we do a little bit
of a report out also because of the fact
that is the instructor since you can't
hear what students are saying you want
to know if there's some big
misconception that's been propagated
during the activity and you want
would want to address that so the report
out in that in that for that exercise
can be particularly important